johnny tu entendras en direct les d'un
bourg à un extrait du concert de
l'économique orchestra donné au profit
de la livre sterling est placée sous le
haut patronage de sa gracieuse majesté
la princesse à n'y a ni ni ni quand
c'est fini ça recommence ou un peu
pâlotte à c'est l'émotion l'émotion
d'être assise à côté d'un beau gosse que
moi tout de suite la bataille pour les
parts première place avec pour commencer
l'étude âge de publicité n'ont pas déjà
écoute beaucoup jallet 6 à caser avant
20 heures car j'ai fait un tube à passer
avant - car ça c'est pas mon boulot
madame chère petite madame si la part de
votre mari sans le bouc
offrez-lui l'after shave de monsieur
seguin avec l'after chèvre de monsieur
seguin vaud pourrait embrasser votre
petit mari sans ferber et maintenant un
peu de musique avant mon prochain coup
c'est on écoute laurent rossi oublie-moi
mandoline
mais bon qu'au premier 8,6 au père
d'udjani ils ont perdu ils ont perdu le
disque de johnny marie-charlotte d